welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss in marvel studios shang chi and the
legend of the 10 rings is one of the
more closer arriving mcu films that is
also a huge
mystery we did explore the fighting
tournament plot from the set visuals in
australia but now production has
surprisingly moved to san francisco
giving us some limited but telling
footage that might actually reveal a lot
about this plot and how it ties into the
broader mcu many of us noticed how
weird it is that marvel during its
latest rescheduling
made this sneaky but pretty significant
shift of bumping
up shang chi from the number three film
spot to the number two film of phase
four
leapfrogging eternals to come out on
july 9th
of next year a move that confirms one
thing at least that marvel is committed
to shang chi being a summer release
a hot-blooded action flick for folks who
just love a good smackdown
and all this is really coming together
to give us a much clearer picture of
this bruce lee inspired fight tournament
film
especially with rumors that many marvel
familiars are going to be joining
this tournament let's fill in the
bracket and break it all down spoiler
warning case you don't want to know but
you do
okay quick refresher shang chi is
marvel's martial arts badass based
directly on the popularity of bruce lee
in the early 70s simulu is playing
shanghai with tony young playing the
true mandarin
the head of the terrorist network that
tony stark crossed paths with in the
iron man movies it's really no secret at
this point that shang chi is going to be
following that fight tournament plot of
bruce lee movies like enter the dragon
which was lee's final film role but one
of his most iconic
the latest news comes from the streets
of san francisco many locals have been
sharing footage and images from the film
set which shows an apparent
high-speed chase through the city
streets involving an articulated city
bus that bendy bus
must get severed at some point because
other footage shows it creating down the
street
with its back car torn off there's also
a photo of a part of the street that was
sectioned off with the pavement just
cracked into
rubble an impact from above you know
like maybe giant scotland not realizing
where he was tripping over on
or as i believe based on some other
footage of construction workers fleeing
this scene in fear perhaps a monster
from below oh and uh patriotic by the
way
if you are interested in fixing this
country's crumbling infrastructure a
great way to let our leaders know
is by voting in person on november 3rd
or early by mail however
is safest for you just do it anyway back
to the nerd stuff okay based on photos
of this production is headquartered near
the hotel fairmont
that geographically places all of this
in or around
sf's historic chinatown district so
beyond enter the dragon a secondary
cinematic influence that i think we are
seeing here is a certain cult classic
starring a
certain mcu celestial kurt russell in
big trouble in little china so while
enter the dragon stars bruce lee is a
fighter in an international tournament
with various quirky participants hosted
by a wealthy criminal
big trouble in little china is a bonkers
80s action comedy about a trucker
getting sucked into an insane plot
involving ancient wizards and
supernatural warriors all in san
francisco's chinatown it's so good
in shangchi's case this chaos we're
seeing in chinatown i believe is either
a set up to
or a consequence of the fighting
tournament plot maybe the second act of
that film
and that tournament we just learned
might include some familiar marvel faces
and others who will be important to
marvel's future which seems to be tying
in every phase four property black widow
doctor strange two
thor four falcon winter soldiers blade
maybe even an mcu deadpool
so we have speculated how shang chief
will sit around this international
fighting tournament hosted in this case
by the mandarin with the prize of this
ancient tournament being
the 10 rings of power and this latest
rumor suggests the mandarin might have
stacked the deck in the tournament to
guarantee the winner of those rings will
be his champion so imagine a bracket
here with 16 open spaces
a sweet 16 that winnows down to an elite
eight then to a final four and then to
the top two in the final match but
before we fill all these slots in look i
know there's a lot of clues we gotta
sift through
because the best visual clues are hiding
in plain sight just like someone's front
pocket wallet like the ridge
thanks to the ridge for sponsoring this
episode the ridge helps you carry what
you need every day
from their flagship ridge wallet to
their portable charging commuter
backpack
they want you to make the most out of
what you're bringing with you the ridge
wallet is made out of military-grade
materials like titanium and carbon fiber
it has a clean stylish design it is
so when jason voorhees is trying to kill
you he won't be able to kill your credit
cards this is their
aluminum silver wallet they do have
other colors including some very flashy
tiki designs
this thing is light it's strong just
like you
they make it easy to buy with free
shipping and free returns and a lifetime
guarantee
it's also got thirty thousand five star
reviews so you know they're doing
something right they also have great
backpacks and travel bags with rfid
blocky pockets and the optional device
charging batteries
get 10 off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com
new rockstars that's ridge.com new
rockstars and use the code
new rockstars find the link in the
video's description okay back to the
bracket chiang chi is our hero
obviously taking one of these slots
another would probably be falo sui
shang chi's sister maybe aquafina's
character though that's not confirmed
both of them in the comics are children
to fu manchu the older comics villain
who didn't really age well and many
believe marvel is retconning to merge
with the mandarin identity according to
these rumors a third spot
would be taken by mordo from the doctor
strange movie
his mission being to gain the 10 rings
to help him rid the world of sorcerers
too many saucers but according to this
rumor mordo would drop
out early after wong makes him sit out
and that mordo spot would be taken by
clive reston an mi6 agent shang chi
works with in the comics and then wong
from therefore would
stick around to council shang chi
another slot rumor has it is going to be
taken by a black widow agent
named felicia maybe one of those many
black widow agents that we meet in black
widow and probably someone we very
quickly say bye to
bafflation now another rumored
participant is going to be bachrock the
leaper
george st pierre's villain to cap and
winter soldier who apparently
is returning the falcon winter soldier
in a possible thunderbolts plot
another maybe warrior would be donica a
female asgardian sent by valkyrie to
investigate and compete in this
tournament maybe a member of her new
valkyrie or
but the big one in this rumor is omega
red arkady rosevich sometimes considered
the russian wolverine
this guy's got long retractable medical
tentacles made of carbonadium which was
the product of soviet attempts to make
adamantium
you might see some parallels here with
red guardian alexis shostakov david
harper's russian cap coming in black
widow
i think that's by design because don't
be surprised if that prison facility
alexi busts out of in black widow also
unleashes characters like omega red
could also tie and backtrack the leaper
as well as felicia
i have speculated in the past that that
facility could also contain other
russian mutants like peter and iliana
rasputin colossus and a sister magic
but rumored taking another tournament
slot would be another mutant the six
armed spiral rita hayward often
associated with longshot the x-men
psylocke we're also hearing maybe whiz
kid described as a techno mutant and
then
t-ray a zombie kind of villain
associated with deadpool in the comics
they also list a native american warrior
named whiteclaw which would be a marvel
deep cut to a character from the 50s
marvel kid called outlaw comics and then
a vampire named evac
which could tie in mahershala ali's
blade film now this rumored report
leaves the rest of the slots open to
other warriors maybe
other mutants that marvel wants to tie
in this universe because really the
exciting element about these tournament
participants isn't the character names
themselves it's the section of the
marvel world
that they come from and what that tells
us about where the mcu
will expand next like for example the
mutants omega red and whiz kid tell us
that marvel
might be implying mutants already exist
in this universe and we're about to meet
a lot more of them
and a lot of those mutants are real fun
to watch in the ring saber tooth
nightcrawler yeah wolverine but
separately we have been hearing from
different rumors that the
dragon thin fang fume will appear awoken
by this tournament now thin fangboom is
the ancient dragon from shang chi in
iron man comics
partner to the mandarin coming actually
from the same alien star system that the
ten mcluhan rings hail from we've been
waiting to see this thing come up in the
mcu and i believe it is totally possible
we will see this thing wreak havoc but
not in china in america which brings us
back
to our sf set videos what if the rubble
those construction workers are fleeing
from
is the emergence of the sleeping dragon
fin fang boom under
the streets of chinatown that bendy bus
that weaves chaotically through the
streets that could
be the dragon having hijacked a city bus
that would be the big trouble little
china finale i'm deep down praying that
we get to see in chiang chi
a mix of the hilly streets of chinatown
along with some horrifying cosmic
mythology really between that and giant
scott lang you can never throw enough at
this city
who else do you want to see in that 10
rings tournament bracket and how would
you play out the matchups chat with me
on new rockstar's official discord
server by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars
subscribe to rockstars hit that
notification bell follow me on instagram
eddie avas following the rockstars thank
you for watching bin bang boom
[Music]
you